you're reuniting with jimmy and it's
sort of
i'm wondering if it's offering you a
chance to do something new
in a different way is is this some is
this another new step new opportunity
for you
oh for sure for sure not only like i
really we so we tracked
we tried we tracked that movie for for
months because i wanted to be
a part of it so bad and we never i never
reached out because i don't want to be
that guy like i don't want to
you know hey denny is their partner you
know i never
wanted to be that guy but he actually um
he called me and he didn't didn't we
didn't say anything he didn't say
anything about you know there's this
part you want
then she just straight out just asked me
if i would come and play this part
and i was so like taken aback i didn't
even know what to say
except for obviously yes absolutely yeah
but
that just like that like moments like
that really
gauge uh how far i've come you know as
an actor
because it's not you know there's a lot
of um
[Music]
there's a lot of pride in it for me that
a director like denny would just call in
and offer me a role
in a film that i know is going to be
enormous because people have been
waiting for this for years and years and
years
and people are so passionate about the
novels
so i knew it was going to be huge and uh
for him to offer me such
you know integral part of this film it's
just i mean for me it was a personal
statement that uh you know you can i
mean i can't
purchase that type of emotion like that
type of feeling that sense of pride i
can't
you know these are the few moments in
life where i get that where i feel
like my life has been you know what my
life was more something i did something
with my life so my life
means something uh you can get me
emotional again
i'm sorry but that's that's the job
um but but we talked to you i think a
few years ago and we were talking about
infinity war collider was talking about
if anyone
you and you mentioned you didn't read
the script the entire script because you
didn't want to
be spoiled i'm wondering if something
with something like dune you did the
same thing or when you got the script
you're like okay i want to see what the
full picture is
yeah yeah i did you know i did that and
i you know i did that with denny and i
did that in blade runner as well and i
said
i don't want to read the script because
i i like to go and like especially stuff
i'm excited about
like i want to go and watch it as a fan
and um
but denny was very insistent that i read
the full script of blade runner because
he wanted to know how i fit into the
film
you know he wanted to know the whole
story how i fit into the film so i could
you know connect my emotions to the
whole story not just to these little
moments that we're creating
and so the same thing with dune i did i
read through the whole script but i
would prefer
um to not read i would like to i would
prefer to the projects that i'm in that
i'm in a you know part like that unless
i'm the lead if i'm a lead in a film i
need to know everything that's going on
i need to know every character
and what their arcs are but for a film
like this where i just serve a certain
purpose in a particular
moment i'd prefer not to read the entire
script because i
i'm at the end of the day i'm a fan
first and i want to go and watch these
films as
a fan so uh but yeah so let's say you
know it's just i don't know part of who
i am i guess
i'm always i always say fanboy first and
that's kind of led me
to every other thing but yeah i like to
uh if i can
you know prevent myself from spoilers
i'd like to do that
i think that the excitement for dune is
kind of reaching like a fever pitch i
think you know when they announced it
was coming to streaming it was like
i think the closer we get to it people
just want to see what this movie is and
i'm wondering what
as a fanboy what was your reaction to
the script
um i was i was blown away i was blown
away i don't think um
it's weird because when i
when i read blade runner when i read
dune
it's hard for me to know what their
visions are
you know especially what denny's vision
is because he's just such
the worlds that he creates are just
they're so enormous like i could never
i don't think i could ever direct a film
like that i think my talent would be
lying and lying a very contained um
drama
like that's what i would like to do
that's what i aspire to do but
creating these even like james like
creating these universes these galaxies
they're just so
far over my head so i read it and i
thought it was beautiful
i was emotionally invested in it and the
script and the characters
but i don't think that my imagination
stretches
that far to create these worlds
so it's it's going to be as big a movie
as people are expecting it's going to be
the event that people are expecting
absolutely yeah absolutely